all right Kendall on to another kind of
family friend Finley Subaru of Las Vegas
the sponsors of this segment is
introducing us to the new saltera
[Music]
our friends at Subaru of Las Vegas are
introducing us to a new friend this
one's name is the super Russo Terra
right Burton yes it is the soltera it's
named after the sun soul and Terra the
Earth and kind of a combination of those
two I love it so tell us
well this new friend is right here the
Subaru soltera and I happen to be
driving one for a demo and it is amazing
I mean it really uh the performance of
it is awesome if you've ever driven an
EV you'll know they have instant torque
they're they're just really fun to drive
they're silent uh so it's very
comfortable driving and I mean it's uh
it really is a winning combination I
would say this is the closest yes very
it's cool at least you are crazy right
um now I also heard that the outdoor
capabilities are out of this world you
can go on adventures with this friend
this is the friend you can road trip
with
when you think of EV oftentimes you
don't think about the capabilities that
you uh if if it's an electric vehicle
it's usually something that's really low
to the ground and not you don't want to
take that too far off Subaru designed
this to go off off the beaten path 8.3
inches of ground clearance is similar to
regular gas powered SUVs and and so it
truly is great off-road and it's got a
dual x mode which means the mud and snow
and those kinds of of uh experiences
that you can have off-roads this can do
it and it can do it great that's cool
that's cool and of course this is Subaru
so all of your cars and vehicles are
extremely safe for the entire family
let's talk about the safety features on
this bad boy you can't uh you can't get
a Subaru that doesn't have safety as as
the Middle Lane
eyesight driver Assist Technology your
automatic emergency braking your lane
keep assist things that will help you to
plan for maybe you don't even see what's
happening up ahead the car is paying
attention it's got radar it does have
things that the cameras that that are
working when you can't see it and it's
you know automatically uh reverse
braking uh you've got a surround View
Camera on most models that you can see
front back sides it's just really a
Subaru well Burton this is a great new
friend to have but how are you guys
giving back to the Friends of our
community we're starting with the little
friends babies Bounty diaper Drive
something that we were doing earlier
this month it stops today but guess what
you can still get in on it whether
you're donating diapers or funds to help
buy diapers we will be accepting
accepting right here at Super of Las
Vegas and then tomorrow May 19th on
Friday American Red Cross blood drive
from 8 till 3 P.M 8 in the morning and
you know what you can make an
appointment by going on to
www.redcross.org org Wright you are such
a great friend to all of us here in Las
Vegas so how about I treat you to lunch
what you drive I buy I love it let's do
it
[Music]
thank you Finley Subaru of Las Vegas for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-495-2197 or visit Subaru of Las
vegas.com they have a special offer for
you 3.9 for up to 48 months on select
new 2023 models for well qualified
buyers